2017 has arrived I am Walter benezia and
welcome to a Happy New Year of top five
the 90s greatest decade ever or greatest
decade ever any 90s kid worth their salt
remembers Nickelodeon from that era and
the impact it had in our formative years
and who could forget the Nicktoons from
the 90s these cartoons were wholly
original and set a tone of success that
our favorite orange-hued cable station
is still enjoying to this day but what
were the best of the best
what Nicktoons back then stuck with us
the most we're here today to find that
out I'm proud to present the top 5 best
90s Nicktoons watt sneak peaks at who or
what I'm covering next want to ask me
more about vintage Nickelodeon or
anything about the 90s well you can
follow me on twitter at awesome
underscore Walter and we can talk about
the 90s until your orange in the face I
also put poles up on there for you guys
to vote on so if you want your voice
heard make sure you check it out this
whole week for a 90's party it's going
to be the bomb who loves nineties
Nicktoons you love nineties Nicktoons
let's get started with number five where
cartoons and comics collide
now to take you inside and turn the
pages here your host Henry and June
in a lot of ways KaBlam was a microcosm
of everything we loved about nineties
Nick it was off-the-wall
unpredictable and featured different
animation styles that resulted in
something very unique and we haven't
seen the likes of it since
KaBlam was an animated sketch comedy
show that was hosted by our page-turners
Henry in June they would introduce each
segment and often have adventures of
their own reoccurring segments included
sniz and fondue life with loopy
Prometheus and Bob and action League now
which later became its own series
hearing that opening theme never failed
to get me excited and you were always in
for an energetic experience when
watching this show what really made it
stick out from the pack was its variety
from short to short we were treated to
different types of comedy and chances
were if you didn't like one segment
you'd like the next the practical
creation of the show is also pretty
impressive when compared to today's
computer-generated standards in addition
to its very funny stop-motion work
KaBlam invented chuckle nation which
combines stop-motion with live-action
shots where the characters were thrown
or dropped into frame and also sometimes
wiggle around when talking this was how
probably the most popular part of the
show actually now was produced the flesh
he's super strong and super naked
she flies like thunder stinky diver a
former Navy commando with an attitude as
bad as his odor and melt man with the
power to the mouth
KaBlam was awesome looking back in it
today really hammers home just how
different it was miss this show will
fear not the creator of Henry and June
mark Merrick has every single episode of
KaBlam available for free on his website
go check out some episodes number four
[Music]
anyway Doug was created by Jim Jenkins
and is absolutely a trademark 90s
Nicktoons even if Disney tried to steal
it away for its final three seasons
Douglas Yancey funnie is an average 11
year old with a wild imagination he
moves to bluffington with his parents
sister Judy and dog porkchop as he makes
new friends and enemies
Doug navigates adolescence in his new
hometown while going through every
emotion a young kid tries to figure out
at his age
his relationships experiences and more
are chronicled daily in his trusty
journal I think a lot of us identify
with dug through the airing of the
series on both Nickelodeon and Disney he
represented the imagined exaggerations
of our hopes and dreams as well as our
fears is an endearing empathetic
character that we want to see do well
he's easy to root for and that dynamic
with the audience sustained the show for
it's four seasons on Nick and beyond we
can't talk about Doug without mentioning
its side characters and very detailed
setting of bluffington each character
became a pretty well-rounded person like
Doug they were also filled with hopes
dreams and fear but represented them in
different ways
even Roger
the happenings in bluffington always led
to interesting situations for the
characters involved for example the
constant presence of mayor white was a
fun way for everyone to stay connected
with what was happening in town and
created some fun stories
Doug's interactions with Skeeter Judy
mr. and mrs. dink and of course his
everlasting crush Patti mayonnaise were
often the heart of the show and they
were easy to instantly take a liking to
with 52 episodes airing in its
Nickelodeon run Doug resonated with a
lot of kids in the 90s and I'm
definitely one of them number 3 that's
right spongebob debuted in 1999 and most
of its first season was air that year
since that whole first season was
produced before the turn of the century
I'll exclusively be talking about second
season and on belongs to the early
two-thousands everyone still seems to
know who spongebob is as his show is
still on the air but just in case
SpongeBob SquarePants lives in a
pineapple in the town of bikini bottom
he enthusiastically works as a fry cook
for the cheap mr. Krabs at the Krusty
Krab with his irritable neighbor
Squidward SpongeBob's inner circle
includes Patrick the starfish sandy the
squirrel and his pet snail Gary together
they engage in more nautical nonsense
than you can shake a wet sponge it says
a lot that just the first season from
the show is so high up on the list many
of those episodes from the first few
seasons are Looney tune level classic I
remember hearing about this show and
seeing a little preview of it before it
officially came out and I was both
unimpressed and confused however once
the show debuted the clever writing
jokes and characters quickly changed my
mind
while classics like rip pants
[Music]
t at the treedome there is not good
Patrick
air is not good you're just being Shawn
and pizza delivery
frosty crazy yeah yeah good pizza the
pizzas ever you in our hilarious and
entertaining spongebob also had a mute
mini episode mixed into its debut called
reef-blower that showed another level of
creativity from everyone who worked on
the show it was immediately obvious
Nickelodeon had a mega hit on its hands
the first season also contains the
debuts of Mermaid Man and Barnacle Boy
who were always good for a laugh I'll
briefly mention here that the show's
popularity and quality seem to only
increase through the first four seasons
after SpongeBob's first movie creator
Stephen Hillenburg resigned as
showrunner and the show seemed to suffer
for it current spongebob episodes are
almost unrecognizable to the genius
content it started off with however
nothing can tarnish the brilliance of
that first season it alone stands
toe-to-toe with the best Nick had to
offer in the decade at debut I'm ready
to move on with the countdown are you
number two
[Music]
before Sponge Bob debuted I think it's
safe to say that Rugrats was the crown
jewel of Nickelodeon's animated projects
Tommy his cousin Angelica and Friends
Chucky Phil and Lil are babies who go on
adventures in everyday life the smallest
things become life-changing events to
these babies as we see them experience
life for the first time including
birthdays baseball games holidays and
more I'm not sure anyone expected a
cartoon about babies to become as big as
it did Rugrats ran from 1991 all the way
to 2004 it also launched three feature
films and a spin-off series because the
characters in this show were so young I
think it continued to connect with new
viewers once they came of age while the
quality of the show
retained the older kids a phenomenon
that sustained the series for many years
the great thing about Rugrats was that
the stories were very interesting and
viewers could relate to experiencing the
world from a similar point of view
seeing things for the first time and
dealing with problems that aren't that
big of a deal
but seem like world ending incidents at
the time are universal themes that even
entertained adult fans of the show the
quality of the show didn't really waver
too much especially in the 90s the first
five plus seasons all aired then and
showcased this series in its prime a
baby's daddy - what a baby's gotta do
while Rugrats was a decently close
second there's only one show in my
opinion that takes the top spot honestly
I loved all those 90s Nick teams as a
kid they were special then and they're
special now however all of them don't
hold up upon rewatching so before we get
to number one here are a few honorable
mentions
[Music]
and the number one best 90s Nicktoons is
there really wasn't much of a choice for
me here Hey Arnold is without a doubt
the best 90s Nicktoons for a plethora of
reasons Arnold is a nine year old boy
who lives with his grandparents in their
boardinghouse
he's a very morally upright kid who
often sees the best in people and their
situations in addition to the crazy
characters who live with him and his
grandparents the neighborhood kids that
Arnold goes to school with are very
important parts of the show's identity
these friends include his closest
confidant Gerald the school klutz Eugene
big bully Harold and tough girl Helga
who claims to hate Arnold in public but
actually has been in love with him for
years with the urban environment they
live in playing as big of a part in many
of the stories as the characters
themselves Hey Arnold is a rich and
surprisingly deep kid show that's
uniquely funny authentic and as
effortlessly cool as its main character
running for five seasons and putting out
a feature film in the process Hey Arnold
is the rare 90s Nicktoons that has
gotten better with age is it any wonder
that Nickelodeon is bringing the show
back to end this series with a TV movie
in November of this year now only the
first four seasons aired in the 90s so
I'll just mention that the ending of the
show in its final season added so much
depth to everything we already saw and
it's impossible to not take that into
account Gold we watch the episode the
journal and if you are a fan of the show
at any point you'll appreciate the
attention to character development that
final episode did for armed besides the
great characters an accurate portrayal
of growing up with your neighborhood
friends hey Arnold is famous for another
distinctive aspect of the show it's
music
[Music]
Jim Lange created themes that added to
the cool nature of the show and cemented
it as something exceptional not many
other shows are as well known for its
music I suggest you find a playlist of
the soundtrack from Hey Arnold and enjoy
these jams creator Craig Bartlett based
the show on his experiences growing up
and was putting Arnold out there in some
form as early as the 80s what Arnold
became was a very well defined character
that almost always did the right thing
but never came off preaching I could
spend a whole episode talking about this
show it's that good if you want to see a
top 5 best Harold episodes in the near
future
comment below there you have it the top
5 best Nick tunes from Nickelodeon's
golden arrow
I want to hear what you guys think what
is your favorite 90s Nick to who or what
do you want me to cover next on the show
leave a comment and let me know follow
me on Twitter at awesome underscore
Walter to take part in more polls about
what I'm a countdown in the future come
back next week for another special
episode of top 5
[Music]
[Applause]
you